belmonte nashville tennessee soy
cristian walker de enbici news y le doy
la bienvenida al último debate
presidencial entre el presidente de
donald trump y el ex vicepresidente joe
biden el debate de esta noche es
patrocinado por el la comisión de
debates presidenciales y está llevado a
cabo bajo las medidas de seguridad la
audiencia ha prometido mantener silencio
lo abuchearan y harán ninguna
interrupción excepto ahora mismo
mientras le damos la bienvenida al ex
vicepresidente joe biden y al presidente
de donald trump
y quiero darle las buenas noches a ambos
este debate va a cubrir seis temas y al
principio de cada sección cada candidato
va a tener dos minutos sin
interrupciones para responder mi primera
pregunta después se van a encender los
micrófonos sólo cuando sean su turno
para responder y la comisión lo va a
apagar cuando estos dos minutos
terminen los dos micrófonos van a estar
después encendidos pero les pedimos por
favor hablar uno a la vez la meta es
escucharnos el uno al otro y que los
estadounidenses escuchen cada palabra de
lo que tienen que decir y si están
listos vamos a empezar y vamos a empezar
con la lucha contra el coronavirus el
presidente trampa esa pregunta es para
usted el
país se dirige a una nueva fase
peligrosa
incluyendo incluidos siempre records
aquí en tennessee
por favor sea específico cómo va a
liderar al país durante esta próxima
fase de el coronavirus bueno como
ustedes saben 2 puntos 2 millones de
personas
se esperaba que murieran
clausuramos la mayor economía del mundo
con el fin de luchar esta horrible
enfermedad que llegó de china es una
pandemia a nivel mundial está en todo el
mundo ustedes ven los picos en europa y
en muchos otros lugares también si se
han dado cuenta la tasa de mortalidad ha
caído un 85% la tasa de exceso de
mortalidad ha bajado mucho más que en
ningún otro país y estamos combatiendo
lo que mucha fortaleza hubo un pico en
florida ahora ya no lo hay hubo una gran
pico en texas y ya se fue hubo un gran
pico en arizona y ya desapareció y hubo
algunos picos y crecientes en otros
lugares que se irán pronto tenemos una
vacuna que está llegando esta lista va a
ser anunciada en unas pocas semanas y va
a ser entregada
tenemos la operación words pib que bueno
es militar los ejército el ejército para
distribuir la vacuna le puedo decir por
experiencia personal que estuve en el
hospital y yo lo tuve me mejore y puedo
debo decir que bueno tuve algo ellos me
dieron una terapia creo que le dirían
así algunos dirían que es una cura pero
yo estuve ahí por un corto periodo de
tiempo y me mejoré muy rápido no estaría
aquí hoy ahora dicen que soy inmune sea
en cuatro meses o toda la vida nadie ha
podido definir lo personal inmune cada
vez más personas están sintiéndose mejor
tuvimos un problema tenemos un problema
a nivel mundial este es un problema a
nivel mundial pero he sido felicitado
por los jefes de muchos países sobre lo
que hemos podido hacer
si usted observa lo que hemos hecho en
términos de bueno gafas máscaras trajes
y todos particularmente ventiladores
solo estamos haciendo ventiladores en
todo el mundo miles y miles
distribuidos en todo el mundo esto
desaparecerá y como yo digo estamos
a la vuelta de la esquina eso se vaya ok
ex-vicepresidente bailén usted cómo va a
liderar al país fuera de esta crisis
tiene dos minutos
doscientos veinte mil personas han
muerto
y no hay nada más que pueda decir esta
noche que esto
cualquier persona que sea responsable de
no tomar control y no decir
simplemente no tomar ninguna
responsabilidad si hay alguien
responsable
por esas muertes no debe ser la persona
que debe seguir en la presidencia de
eeuu
estamos registrando 100 muertes al día
y cada vez más casos al día
comparado con lo que está sucediendo en
europa
está empezando desde una tasa muy bajo a
una muy alta la expectativa es que
tengamos
otros 200.000 estadounidenses fallecidos
hasta final del año solo usan esta
máscara
los
consejeros del presidente se lo dijeron
y si hubieran salvado miles de vidas
el presidente aún no tiene ningún plan
no tiene un plan amplio lo que yo voy a
hacer es asegurarme de que todas las
personas usen una máscara todo el tiempo
me voy a hacer asegurarte esto y que
invirtamos en hacer pruebas rápidas y me
voy a asegurar de que establezcamos
estándares nacionales para abrir las
escuelas y abrir los negocios para que
sean seguros y darle los recursos
financieros para que lo puedan hacer una
situación en la que estamos ahora
cuando una de las revistas más serias
científicas ha dicho por primera vez que
la forma en la que el presidente
respondió a esta crisis ha sido trágica
así que me voy a hacer cargo de esto lo
voy a terminar y me voy a asegurar de
que tengamos un plan presidente trump
quisiera seguir con usted y con sus
comentarios usted está diciendo que toma
un medicamento terapéutico y también
dijo que una vacuna va a llegar en
semanas eso es una garantía no no es una
garantía pero lo será para el final del
año creo que hay una gran oportunidad de
con estas dos compañías creo que en un
plazo de semanas y será distribuído
rápidamente
johnson y johnson está haciéndolo muy
bien moderna también está haciéndolo
bien
fisher lo está haciendo bien y hay
varias son numerosas también tenemos hay
otras con las que estamos trabajando muy
de cerca con nuestros países
particularmente en europa déjeme hacerle
seguimiento a esto porque esta es
información nueva usted ha dicho que una
vacuna va a llegar ahora en semanas
y había dicho que podría ser los
oficiales las autoridades han dicho que
será hasta 2021 e incluso dicen que
hasta entonces se usarán máscaras hasta
2022 pero en realidad el tiempo va a ser
mucho más precisa no sé si están
contando con el ejército como yo lo hago
pero tenemos generales haciendo fila uno
en particular es el jefe de logística
y esta es una distribución bastante
sencilla él está listo para empezar tan
pronto como tengamos la vacuna y
esperamos tener 100 millones de dosis a
tramposo como les tengamos él es el de
suficiente baile en su redacción el 40
por ciento de los estadounidenses dicen
que tomarían esta vacuna si estuviera
aprobada por el gobierno usted qué pasos
daría para darles confianza en una
vacuna si fuera aprobada
me voy a hacer asegurar de que sea
completamente transparente de que el
mundo la vea vaya a todos los procesos
esta es la misma persona que les dijo
que iba a ser en primavera no se
preocupen vamos a terminar este virus en
el verano y ya estamos entrando en un
invierno sombrío y él no tiene un plan
claro no tiene prospectos de que vaya a
haber una vacuna disponible para la
mayoría de los estadounidenses antes de
la mitad del próximo año presidente de
trump su reacción no creo que vamos a
tener un invierno muy oscuro en absoluto
estamos abriendo nuestro país hemos
aprendido hemos estudiado hoy hemos
entendido a la enfermedad que nos
teníamos al principio cuando cerré el
país cuando vete a los chinos de venir
porque están muy afectados y finalmente
europa china estaba en europa bueno
meses después se les estaba diciendo que
yo era ser un fóbico que lo hice me
pronto le está diciendo que debí haberlo
bueno haberlo hecho más rápido pero él
no se movimos rápido él estuvo meses
detrás mío meses retrasados francamente
el manejo el a h1n1 la gripe porcina y
fue un completo desastre mucho menos
letal pero fue un desastre completo si
eso hubiese tenido este tipo de cifras
700 mil personas hubieran muerto ahora
pero era una enfermedad mucho menos
letal miren a su persona la persona que
manejó eso por él como saben era su jefe
de gabinete dijo que fue catastrófico
que fue horrible y no sabíamos lo que
estábamos haciendo ahora él viene y nos
dice cómo hacer esto también todo lo que
él ha dicho sobre el ama por cierto todo
lo que dice cada movimiento que dijimos
todo lo hicimos nosotros pero él estuvo
mucho muy [__] recientes respuestas
mi respuesta es que él
no cerró el acceso a china después de
que 40 países lo hicieran y después de
esto se aseguró de que las personas que
tenían
que tratar de llegar a one para tratar
de decir sé cuál era la causa que dijo
él en enero él decía que era
transparente el presidente de china de
transparente le tenemos que dar gratitud
tenemos que agradecerle y qué pasó
después empezamos a hablar de la defensa
de asegurarnos que de tener todo lo que
necesitábamos para proteger a la gente y
de nuevo regreso a esto él no hizo
virtualmente nada luego sale del
hospital y habla no se preocupen
se va a terminar pronto por favor
no hay un científico que piense que se
va a acabar pronto
pronto dice que estamos aprendiendo
manejarla no tenemos opciones no tenemos
ni podemos encerrarnos en un bueno
sótano como yo google tiene la habilidad
de encerrarse obviamente él ha hecho
mucho dinero de alguna manera pero es
esto de vivir en un sótano la gente no
puede hacer eso por cierto yo como el
presidente no pude serlo quisiera
meterme en un sótano en una habitación
hermosa de la casa blanca alejarme por
año y medio hasta que esto se acabe no
puedo hacerlo cada reunión que tengo
cada reunión que he tenido he conocido
muchas familias incluyendo familias del
ejército cada reunión tuve que
encontrarme con ellos tuve que hacerlo
hubiera sido horrible cancelarlo pero
dije saben esto es peligroso y bueno
ustedes pueden enfermarse y yo me
enfermé aprendí muchísimo tuve grandes
doctores estuve un hospital increíble
ahora me recuperé
99.9 por ciento de la gente joven se
recupera 99% de la gente se recupera
tenemos que recuperarnos no podemos
cerrar nuestra nación tenemos que abrir
nuestras escuelas y no podemos cerrar
nuestra nación o no van a tener una
nación y por supuesto los centros de
control de enfermedades han dicho que
las personas se pueden enfermar pero
pueden superar quiero hablar con el
vicepresidente sobre la estrategia puedo
responder a eso primero él dice que
estamos aprendiendo a vivir con él la
gente está aprendiendo a morir con él
ustedes en casa van a tener una mesa una
silla vacía en su mesa y van a tratar de
ir a tocar a su esposo en la cama o su
esposa y no y se ha ido a aprender a
vivir con ello por favor estamos
muriendo porque él nunca ha dicho nunca
dijo que era preso peligroso es
peligroso dígale a la gente si es
peligroso ahora qué deben hacer sobre
este peligro y dice no tengo ninguna
responsabilidad déjeme hablar discúlpeme
rápidamente asumo toda la
responsabilidad
esto no es mi culpa no es mi culpa que
haya venido es culpa de china y sabe no
es culpa de china que haya llegado
tampoco es la culpa de china ellos lo
ocultaron lo mantuvieron en china pero
no impidieron que saliera el mundo
incluyendo europa incluyendo nosotros
el hecho es que cuando sabíamos que iba
a llegar qué pasó qué hizo el presidente
dijo no se preocupen se va a ir se va a
ir en primavera no se preocupen se va a
ir en con el clima cálido y mucha gente
pensaba que era serio y los hizo
cambiarlo muchas cosas de los que ha
dicho el presidente incluso hoy cree que
estamos en control y vamos a perder
200.000 personas más presidente de
transferencias miren posiblemente para
terminar esta parte
yo estaba bromeando sí pero hay que
terminar eso cuando yo cerré dije él
dijo que yo no debí haber cerrado el
país y eso pasó sigue por meses nancy
pelosi dijo lo mismo estaba bailando en
las calles en chinatown en san francisco
pero cuando yo hice el cierre él dijo
que era algo terrible que era xenofóbico
creo que incluso me llamó racista
y ya que estaba cerrando el país a china
ahora dicen que debió haberlo hecho
antes
joe es si no funciona y si lo hiciste si
lo hiciste debería cerrar y lees sobre
su xenofobia en otro contexto que no se
trataba de cerrar las fronteras a los
chinos a que llegaran a eeuu quería
hablar de ustedes de sus extra él pensó
que no debí haber cerrado la frontera
eso es obvio quiere responder a eso ha
visto presidente no vamos a hablar sobre
sus diferentes estrategias para lidiar
con este vicepresidente usted dice que
usted apoya lo que los científicos
recomiendan que le dice a los
estadounidenses que tienen miedo a los
cierres a la depresión al
abuso doméstico y en vez de exponerse al
virus lo que dije era que quería cerrar
el virus no al país
este este el virus le causó que el país
tuviera que ser cerrado muchas escuelas
y muchas personas perdieron su trabajo
pero hay otras preocupaciones que son
reales y por esto
él debió haber negociado con nancy
pelosi con el resto de los demócratas
sobre qué hacer
y con miles de millones de dólares para
que muchas personas tengan la capacidad
de enfrentarse
no estoy a favor de esto se necesitan
estándar si tenemos una tasa
contagios que está sobre los niveles se
debe tomar más distancia social no habrá
bares no habrán gimnasios no habrán
hasta que tengan esto bajo control pero
cuando abran denle a la gente la
capacidad de tener esta capacidad para
abrir y hacerlo a salvo por ejemplo las
escuelas las escuelas necesitan mucho
dinero necesitan sistemas de ventilación
clases más pequeñas más maestros y él se
niega a dar este dinero hasta ahora
vamos a hablar de las escuelas pero creo
que hay que responder su amor y luego
tengo aprecio mucho mire todo lo que él
hace es hablar de los cierres pero
olvídense de él sus gobernadores
demócratas como nueva york miren lo que
está pasando también en california miren
pensilvania carolina del norte los
demócratas de demostrar así todos
cerraron todo con tanto
y ahora están muriendo y él respalda a
toda esta gente todo de lo que habla el
cierre si no no vamos a hacer cierres
tenemos que abrir nuestras escuelas y es
como un ejemplo tengo un joven hijo él
también tuvo una prueba positivos para
el punto del cable con el doctor la
segunda vez el yo estaba bien
simplemente se fue la gente joven creo
que su sistema inmune favor déjenme
seguir los presidentes trump usted pidió
que se abrieran las escuelas y dijo que
se podía hacer de manera segura pero
ayer boston se cumplió se convirtió en
el primer sistema completamente online
cuál es su mensaje para los padres que
creen que enviar a sus hijos a la
escuela los pone en peligro
voy a quiero abrir las escuelas
la tasa de transmisión en los profesores
es baja quiero abrir las escuelas y
tenemos que abrir el país si no no vamos
a tener país ustedes no pueden hacer eso
no podemos hacer eso y mantener el país
cerrado ayer es un país gigante con una
economía masiva la gente está perdiendo
y sus trabajos cometen suicidios hay
depresión alcohol y drogas a un nivel
que nadie nunca visto antes hay abusos
un abuso tremendo tenemos que abrir
nuestro país
lo he dicho frecuentemente la cura no
puede ser peor que el problema en sí
mismo y eso es lo que está pasando y él
quiere hacer cierres y él va a cerrar ya
clausurar el país si una persona en
nuestro sistema burocrático masivo dice
que si el presidente va a ir en su
respuesta no sencillamente no es cierto
no podemos caminar y masticar goma de
mascar
se necesita abrir pero se necesitan
recursos para abrir si se abre un
negocio tener distancia social dentro de
este se necesita tener un restaurante
con sus divisores de plexiglás para que
la gente no pueda contagiarse los unos a
los otros se debe estar en una posición
donde se puede hacer pruebas rápidas
para que ninguna persona para saber si
ninguna persona está infectada
necesitamos tener los los recursos
disponibles para que se pueda hacer y
esto no es inconsistente con nada decir
bueno vamos a asegurarnos de abrir con
seguridad saquemos a los
los profesores no se preocupen por favor
no hay que decir esto si uno observa lo
que está pasando en nueva york es un
pueblo fantasma es un pueblo fantasma y
cuando uno habla del flexibles son
restaurantes que ya están muriendo son
negocios que ya no tienen dinero tienen
que poner un plexiglás es increíblemente
peligroso costoso y no es la respuesta
se va a sentar ahí usted en un cubículo
envuelto en plástico son negocios que
están muriendo yo no puedes hacerle eso
a la gente simplemente no puedes mira
nueva york' mira lo que está pasando a
mi hermosa ciudad
tantos años la amado es vibrante ahora
está muriendo todo el mundo se está
yendo de un medio debe mirar lo que
nueva york ha hecho en términos de
reducir la curva y no lo veo en los
mismos términos que los estados rojos y
los azules todos somos estados unidos
pero los estados que tienen un alza en
casos de coronavirus y hay estados rojos
y hay otros en el centro del país
y hay otros donde hay más
significativamente cada vez más y más
casos pero todos somos estadounidenses y
lo que tenemos que hacer es usar estas
mascarillas y asegurarnos de darles las
ayudas a los negocios que necesita que
necesitan el dinero ya fue aprobado
desde el principio del verano y nada ha
pasado
es nueva york ha perdido más de 40.000
personas
11 mil versiones de ayuda cuando se
habla de un pico mire lo que está
pasando en pensilvania donde hubo
cierres miren lo que está pasando con su
amigo en michigan donde
los puestos gnósticos que pueden hacer
algo es como una prisión ahora se acaba
de fallar como inconstitucional miren lo
que pasa en carolina del norte están
teniendo picos y han estado cerrados y
es tan bueno muriendo financieramente no
podemos permitir que eso pase de joe tú
no puedes dejar que eso pase tenemos que
abrirnos y entendemos la enfermedad
tenemos que proteger a nuestros ancianos
tenemos que proteger especialmente a la
gente que tiene de situaciones
coronarias diabetes y los protegeremos
el mejor sistema de pruebas
antes de movernos a la siguiente sección
usted le dijo al doctor anthony fauci un
desastre lo describió como idiotas y
sino
incluyendo en tour y me llevo muy bien
con anthony pero él sí dijo que no
utilicen máscaras el sí dijo como
ustedes saben que esto no iba a ser un
problema yo creo que él es un demócrata
por eso está bien él dijo que esto no
iba a ser un problema y no vamos a tener
un problema cuando yo dice que yo dije
que antonio chaouchi dijo y otros y
muchos otros y no estoy al tanto lo que
nadie sabía nadie sabía que era esto
nadie sabía de dónde venía que era y
hemos aprendido mucho pero anthony dijo
no utilice más granada dice que
utilicemos máscaras altube y también
dijo que si miramos hacia atrás miren
palabras exactas esto no es un problema
esto se va a ir pronto entonces a él se
le permite cometer errores
respuesta rápidamente y vamos a ponernos
a la siguiente sección piensen en lo que
el presidente sabía en enero y no le
dijo a los estadounidenses
le dijieron que esta era una enfermedad
seria y que era mucho peor que la gripe
él dijo
a uno de sus colegas no esto quedó
grabado que sabía lo peligroso que era
pero no quería decirnos no quería
decirnos porque no quería que tuviéramos
pánico no quiero que los estadounidenses
tuvieran tuvieran pánico pero mientras
tanto nos dimos cuenta que el 'new york
times' el otro día sus amigos fueron a
wall street dijeron esto es algo muy
peligroso
y gente de su administración y algunos
de los accionistas dijeron si tenemos
que movernos es un peligroso
para responder y vamos a construir que
alguien fue wells y tú tú eres el que
toma todo el dinero de bolsillo no lo
tomo tú has hablado has tenido mucho
dinero mucho mucho dinero y cada vez que
reúnes dinero hay tratos
yo puedo reunir el dinero tanto dinero
como presidente y como persona que
conoce a muchas de esas personas los
jefes de wall street a los jefes de cada
compañía de eeuu yo podría sorprender y
acabar cada récord pero no quiero
hacerlo porque me pone en una mala
posición y luego tú hablas de walk signo
deberías estar hablando de walking
porque tú eres el que recibe el dinero
de hueso y no soy yo yo podría acabar
con todos sus récords como lo podrías
que no necesitamos dinero tenemos
suficiente dinero de hecho acabamos con
hillary clinton con una mínima fracción
cada contribución es de 43 dólares vamos
a seguir con nuestra siguiente sección
nación seguridad nacional quiero empezar
con las noticias que llegaron apenas
esta noche que confirmaron que tanto
rusia como irán están trabajando para
influir en esta dirección ambos países
han obtenido datos de votantes y están
intimidando a los votantes de florida
esta pregunta vado para usted es
vicepresidente qué va a hacer para
terminar con esta amenaza tiene dos
minutos
lo deje claro y que quiero que los demás
lo sepan dejado claro que cualquier país
sin importar quién sea si interfiere en
las elecciones estadounidenses va a
pagar un precio ha sido claro en esta
elección no voy a hablar del anterior
pero esta elección rosa rusia y china
han estado involucrados y ya ahora nos
hemos dado cuenta que irán también ellos
van a pagar un precio si yo soy electo
no pueden interferir con la soberanía
estadounidense y esto es lo que están
haciendo ahora
y para mi conocimiento no creo que el
presidente haya dicho nada a putin no
creo que les dijera una palabra en los
muchos veces que ha hablado con ellos no
sé por qué no le ha dicho nada a putin y
sé que lo que recientemente ha dicho a
los iraníes es que seguramente no ha
hablado con ellos pero no les ha dicho
nada el punto es este estamos en una
situación en la que no
tenemos muchos países tratando de
interferir en nuestras elecciones
nuestro consejero de seguridad nacional
le dijo bueno su amigo rudy giuliani
estaba siendo usado por rusia le han
dado información que no es cierta y
luego que pasa nada pasa y luego nos
damos cuenta que todo lo que está
sucediendo aquí sobre rusia es que está
tratando de asegurarse de que yo no sea
el próximo presidente porque ellos saben
que yo los conozco y ellos me conocen no
entiendo por qué este presidente
no puede hacerle nada a putin
cuando les está poniendo precio a la
cabeza de los soldados estadounidenses
en afganistán cuando está tratando de
desestabilizar a toda la otan no sé por
qué el presidente no hace nada porque no
se hace nada cualquier país que
interfiere con nosotros va a pagar un
precio porque están afectando a nuestra
soberanía presidente trump la misma
pregunta para déjenme hacer la presión
se va a tener dos minutos y dos
selecciones que han sido intervenidas
por adversarios que va a ser en su
próximo término para buena espina debe
responder a la primera parte como yo
respondió youtube tres millones y medio
de dólares de rusia y que llegaron a
través de footing porque él fue muy
amistoso con el ex alcalde de moscú
la esposa y recibiste tres millones y
medio de dólares tu familia los recibió
algún día vas a tener que explicar por
qué recibiste eso yo jamás he recibido
dinero de los ello no recibo dinero de
rusia ahora respecto de lo que pasó
anoche yo lo sabía todo a través de john
john radcliffe que es un director de
inteligencia para chico
dijo que lo único que sale de ellos es
que ambos quieren que tú pierdas porque
no hay nadie que ha sido más drástico
con rusia entre las sanciones no hay
nadie que haya sido más rudo que yo
corrió entre las sanciones entre todo lo
que he hecho con lo tan tengo los países
de la otan tengo que hice que pusieran
1.3 mil millones de dólares dice que
incrementarán su contribución anual eso
fue lo que hice en contra de rusia
mientras él estaba vendiendo almohadas y
sábanas yo vendí rompe tanques a ucrania
no hay nadie más duro con rusia que
donald trump
y yo puedo decir algo ellos hicieron tan
mal que tomaron el puerto de submarinos
te acuerdes de eso bien cierto durante
tu periodo durante tu periodo y el de
barack obama usted tomar una buena parte
de lo que debió haber sido ucrania tu se
los entregaste ustedes se lo hicieron
pero recibían mucho dinero de rusia
ellos estaban pagando les mucho dinero y
posiblemente siguen haciéndolo pero
ahora con lo que salió hoy es mucho peor
todos los emails estos emails horribles
el tipo de dinero que ustedes estaban
recibiendo tú y tu familia yo tú como
vicepresidente viste como pasado a esto
y nunca debió haber sucedido y yo creo
que le debes una explicación al pueblo
estadounidense porque alguien acaba de
tener una rueda de prensa hacia focos
esencialmente se suponía que trabajaba
contigo y tu familia debía hacerlo lo
que dijo fue condenatorio y sin importar
yo creo que tienes que limpiar te y
hablar con el pueblo estadounidense de
pronto puedes hacerlo ahora algo visto
presidente puede responder pues quiero
hacer un seguimiento a esto no he tomado
un centavo de ninguna fuente extranjera
nunca en mi vida aprendimos que este
presidente pagó 50 veces impuestos en
china con una cuenta secreta hace
negocios en china y de hecho está
hablando de mí tomando dinero nunca he
tomado un centavo de ningún otro país
nunca en primer lugar segundo lugar
este es un presidente que yo he liberado
todos mis impuestos 22 años de mis
declaraciones de impuestos y usted
lo ha hecho nunca que está escondiendo
porque los países extranjeros están
pagando rusia les está pagando china le
está pagando y sus hoteles y todos sus
negocios en todo el país todo el mundo
china está en esta cultura
construyendo una cancha de golf que está
pasando aquí porque no libera sus
declaraciones de impuestos y deje de
hablar de corrupción en primer lugar yo
llamé a mis contadores
estoy bajo auditoría y lo voy a librar
tan pronto posible yo quiero hacerlo y
ahí se mostrará lo exitoso lo grande que
es esta compañía pero mucho más
importante la gente estaba diciendo que
de 750 dólares yo les pregunté hace una
semana que pagues y eso dijeron señor
usted hizo pre pagos de decenas de
millones de dólares dice prepago de mis
impuestos en los anteriores años decenas
de millones de dólares yo he hecho pre
pagos porque en cierto punto ellos creen
que es un estimado ellos creen que pueda
tener que pagar impuestos entonces yo ya
hago pre pagos alguien me dijo eso nadie
contado el artículo
cuando sea que en eso siguen hablando de
750 dólares creo que eso es una
cuenta de archivos yo pago millones y
millones de dólares en impuestos en
número uno número dos yo no recibo
dinero de china usted lo haces tú lo
haces yo no recibo dinero de ucrania tú
lo recibes yo no recibo dinero de rusia
tú hiciste 3.5 millones de dólares joe y
tu hijo te los dio incluso tienen una
declaración que dice que ha quedado un
10% al gran hombre y tú eres el gran
hombre creo yo no sé de pronto no pero
tú eres el día de nombre creo yo en el
sentido en que que darle un 10% el gran
hombre yo de qué se trata todo eso es
terrible caballeros quiero preguntarles
a los dos algunas preguntas pero si
quiero responder luego les voy a dar
responder rápidamente usted dijo que
habló de su contador sobre publicar sus
impuestos tan pronto como sea que mire
la fecha para hacer yo recibo un
tratamiento peor que el tea party porque
hay mucha gente ahí que están bien
metidas en el fisco me tratan
terriblemente hicimos un trato ya todo
estaba resuelto hasta que yo decido
correr para presidente que tratan muy
mal en el fisco muy injustamente
ya teníamos un trato de hecho tan pronto
como fue completado el trato yo quiero
liberarlo pero he pagado millones y
millones de dólares y es peor que pagar
pago en avance se llama otro pago quiero
preguntarles a ambos preguntas sobre
sus enredos potenciales con el
extranjero vamos a hablar de esto más
ampliamente responda rápidamente y voy a
hacer me pregunto si él ha estado
diciendo esto durante cuatro años
muestra nosotros nuestro no simplemente
deje de jugarse usted ha dicho durante
cuatro años que va a mostrarnos sus
impuestos y nadie sabe lo que usted paga
y lo que estaba en el que usted no está
pagando o está pagando impuestos están
bajos la última vez que dijo era que
sólo pague un poco porque soy
inteligente sé cómo jugar con el sistema
por favor bueno presidente de trump
quiero hacer dos preguntas a los dos
a mí me hicieron atravesar una cacería
de brujas ridículas durante tres años
empezó antes de resultar elegido
espiaron a mi campaña ningún presidente
tuvo que haber atravesado lo que yo
atravesé simplemente déjeme decir esto
müller y 18 demócratas enojados y
agentes del fbi en todas partes casas
gastaron 48 millones de dólares
metieron ahí todo lo que yo tenía
incluyendo la información fiscal hirió
encontraron colusión no encontraron
absolutamente nada errado 48 millones yo
les garantizo
si yo gastará un millón joey podría
contar muchas cosas mal aunque es el
tipo de cosas las que tú has hecho el
tipo de dinero es que tu familia ha
recibido es decir tu hermano y su dinero
mírame millones de dólares tu otro
hermano hizo una fortuna y eso es a
través tuyo y dicen que tú recibes parte
y que vives humilde no tienes que hacer
todas partes y que vives muy bien hay
caballeros por favor déjenme hacerle
unas preguntas sobre todo esto
vicepresidente hay preguntas sobre el
trabajo que su hijo ha hecho en china y
en compañías ucranianas cuando usted era
vicepresidente hay algo sobre estas
relaciones que pueden no ético o
inapropiados nada fue poco ético ni
inapropiada
respecto a ucrania
nos hemos preguntado
sobre esto mucho él estaba en la junta
de esta compañía por si había hecho algo
mal pero todas las personas cuando él
estaba atravesando a su juicio en el
senado de impeachment decía que yo hice
mi trabajo impecablemente lleve a cabo
las políticas estadounidenses
nada estaba fuera del lugar ni siquiera
una sola cosa en primer lugar en segundo
lugar es él fue el que se metió en
problemas de nucleares tratando de
sobornar los para que dijeran algo
negativo hacia mí lo cual no iban a
hacer y no hicieron porque nunca pasó mi
hijo no ha hecho dinero en términos de
eso que está hablando de china no el
único personaje que ha hecho dinero de
china es esta persona nadie más ha hecho
dinero de china presidente
por cierto puedo puedo decir una cosita
rápidamente su hijo no tenía trabajo no
estuvo mucho tiempo tristemente no
estaba en el servicio militar no voy a
hablar de eso y no tenía trabajo tan
pronto como él se volvió vice vidente
turismo no que no era que no tenía la
mejor reputación del mundo lo escucho
que le pagan
183 mil al mes escuchen esto 183 y le
dan un pago con tal de tres millones
dobles si no tenía experiencia energía
en sus cuentas yo por situaciones por
favor
cualquier persona que investigó esto
nadie dijo que había algo equivocado en
el 'top reciente trompetas para usted
usted nunca se separó de sus negocios y
siguió promoviendo sus negocios en el
exterior y su compañía tiene una cuenta
bancaria en china como los votantes
saben que no tienen ningún conflicto yo
tengo muchas cuentas bancarias y todas
están listadas y están en todas partes
yo era un empresario que estaba haciendo
negocios la cuenta de banco a la que
usted se refiere todo el mundo sabe ella
está en una lista esa cuenta
abierta en 2013 ahí estaba y fue cerrada
en 2015 creo y luego decidido ya que iba
a ser estaba pensando hacer un trata en
china como millones de otras personas
estaba pensando en ello y he decidido
que no voy a hacerlo bueno que no me
gustaba decir y no hacerlo tuve una
cuenta del abril y lasserre disculpe y
luego a diferencia de él cuando es
vicepresidente de negocios yo decidido
aspirar a la presidencia después de eso
fue antes entonces yo la cerré antes de
siquiera aspirar a la presidencia
mucho menos convertirme en presidente y
una gran diferencia
él es el vicepresidente de los eeuu y su
hijo su hermano y su otro hermano están
enriqueciéndose son como una aspiradora
que
van a seguir quiero preguntarles
vicepresidente biden sobre china vamos a
hablar sobre china más ampliamente
hay por supuesto el presidente de trump
dicen que deben pasar por no pagar por
no ser transparente sobre el coronavirus
si usted fuera presidente les haría
pagar y que haría lo que haría sería que
jueguen con las leyes internacionales no
como él lo ha hecho él ha causado que el
déficit con china crezca
no disminuya nos aseguraremos de que
para hacer negocios con china tienes que
hacer toda tu propiedad intelectual y
tener
socio y en segundo lugar en una
situación en la que china va a tener que
regirse por las leyes internacionales
cuando yo era vicepresidente vamos a
establecer zonas de
identificación y vamos a volar a través
de ella con
b-52 ellos tienen que jugar bajo las
normas internacionales y que
él abraza a dictadores como el
presidente chino putting el de corea del
norte y está alejándose de todos
nuestros aliados
teníamos el 25 por ciento de la economía
mundial y tenemos que tener a nuestros
amigos con nosotros estas son las reglas
y jugamos con las reglas y si no lo
hacemos
debemos pagar las consecuencias
económicas y esa es la manera en la que
yo lo haría cuando yo sea presidente ok
vamos a hablar un momento un momento yo
tengo que responder a eso
rápidamente
salió
después de pasar 10 minutos en el cargo
y estar en el air force huesos en primer
lugar en segundo lugar hay una muy
fuerte discutiendo que su familia quería
hacer 10 millones de dólares al año por
presentaciones sobre la política de un
hombre que va a ser usted
específicamente que va a ser
específicamente para que
miles de
nuestros granjeros mientras china
está el dinero de los contribuyentes y
es el dinero de los buenos
contribuyentes a china son 28 millones
sabes que hicieron ellos de valor de su
moneda de también pagaron y sabe que
quiere recibir dinero nuestros granjeros
nuestros grandes viajeros porque ellos
les dimos el dinero usted nunca les
cobró nada ahora también descubre 25% en
el cero porque no si estaba matando en
el acero ahora tenemos una industria en
su respuesta por favor
esto no se trata hay una razón por la
que él hace esto hay una razón para esto
no quería hablar sobre las
divisiones sustanciales no se trata de
mi familia y su familia se trata de su
familia y su familia está sufriendo si
usted es una familia de la clase media
usted está siendo herido gravemente
ahora usted estaba esta mañana
desayunando y decidiendo sobre si tenía
que comprar nuevas llantas para sus
carros o si iba a pagar la hipoteca o si
su hipoteca o si algunos de sus hijos
iba a ir a la universidad como en las
familias en las que yo crecí están en
problemas y deberíamos hablar sobre sus
familias y eso es lo último de lo que él
quiere hablar eso quiero hablar yo del
currículo probablemente diez segundos
señor presidente eso es una declaración
política típica sacamos de lo de china y
luego mire la familia alrededor de la
mesa todo lo que quieren es un político
típico
por eso fue que a mí me eligieron vamos
a hablar salgamos del tema de chira y
hablemos de sentarnos alredor de la mesa
por favor yo tienes que ser lo mejor
de corea del norte presidente usted se
reunió con el líder de este país si
usted habló de hermosas cartas con él
ha hablado sobre sus avances pero sin
embargo él presentó recientemente su
misil balístico más grande y sigue
aumentando su no arsenal ve esto como un
empeoramiento de la relación cuando me
encontré con barack obama nos sentamos
en la casa blanca justo al principio
tuvimos una gran conversación se suponía
que iba a pasar 15 minutos y fue mucho
más de una hora él dijo que el problema
más grande que tenemos es corea del
norte él indicó que estaríamos en guerra
con corea del norte y saben que sería
una guerra nuclear y si hay mucha
capacidad nuclear ahí pero mientras
tanto yo tengo una gran relación con él
un tipo diferente pero posiblemente cree
lo mismo de mí tenemos una relación un
poco diferente tenemos una muy buena
relación y no hay guerra y sabes acerca
de hace dos meses el centro de ciertas
días dijeron bueno que iba a haber
problemas yo dije no no no no va a pasar
porque él no lo va a hacer y estaba lo
correcto está en lo correcto en vez de
estar una guerra donde millones de
personas bueno miren ustedes vieron 25
millas de distancia millones y millones
300 millones de personas en seguros
en relación con el vidente corea del
norte hizo cuatro pruebas nucleares
sobre la administración obama porque
usted podría hacer algo diferente
porque hemos dejado claro como china que
tiene que hacer parte de un acuerdo y lo
hice
como portavoz cuando fui a china porque
están acercando tanto sus misiles porque
están moviendo más fuerzas aquí porque
siguen
haciendo maniobras con corea del norte
porque corea del norte es un problema y
vamos a seguir haciéndolo para
controlarlos vamos a asegurarnos de
poder controlarlos y que no puedan
dividirnos así que si quieren hacer algo
deben tomar un paso adelante si no va a
continuar el lo que ha hecho es
legitimar los ha dicho que es un gran
amigo y habla de cómo estamos mejores y
qué y ellos ahora tienen mejores misiles
que pueden llegar al territorio
estadounidense más rápido que nunca
antes déjenme seguirlo prince presidente
usted no se reuniría sin ningunas
condiciones cuáles son las condiciones
en la condición de que
él escriba su capacidad nuclear
y que debe hacer una zona libre nuclear
diez años intentaron encontrarse con él
y yo no lo hizo a él no le gustaba
y está bien porque corea del norte no
estamos en guerra tenemos una buena
relación y sabe la gente tener una buena
relación con los otros países muchas
preguntas si
él se hubiera reunido con hitler antes
de invadir europa por favor
la única razón por la que no se reuniría
con el presidente obama es porque dijo
que iba a hablar de desnuclearización no
lo iba a ser más fuerte y vamos seguir
poniéndole sanciones y por eso es que no
se iba a reunir con nosotros
corea del norte necesitamos
un periodo muy peligroso mis primeros
tres meses antes de siquiera empezar
mejorar las cosas ya cuarta vez y estás
ellos nos dejaron un desastre y obama
creo que sería el primero en decir que
era el ritmo más importante que él creía
que íbamos a avanzar con las familias
estadounidenses y la economía uno de los
asuntos que es más importante para ellos
es el cuidado de salud como lo saben hoy
hubo un voto clave sobre la corte
suprema de justicia y nikon y parets
como lo saben más de 20 millones de
estadounidenses tienen su seguridad
social a través de la ley de cuidado de
salud asequible el obamacare
si la corte suprema- quita esta ley 20
millones de estadounidenses pueden
perder su seguro así quedaría usted si
estas personas tienen sus seguros de
salud claro en primer lugar ya he hecho
algo que nadie creyó que era posible a
través de la legislatura acabe con el
mandato individual que era la peor parte
del obamacare como lo llamamos el
mandato individual donde había que pagar
una fortuna por el privilegio de no
tener que pagar por un seguro malo yo
acabé con eso y eso se acabó ahora está
en la corte porque obama care no es
bueno pero toma una decisión maneje lo
mejor posible para mi gente les dije lo
mejor posible manejen lo mejor posible
pude haber ido por la otra ruta y hacer
que todo el mundo fuera muy feliz y
ellos solo manejaron los premios están
decayendo todo está pasando por eso se
programan sin importar lo bien que sea
manejado no se puede hacer nada lo que
yo quiero hacer es terminarlo tenemos el
mandato individual y eso se acabó yo no
sé si vaya a funcionar y si no ganamos
tenemos que manejarlo y tendremos
schumacher pero será mejor manejado y ya
no es obama que de todas formas porque
sí el mandato individual es mucho más
diferente las condiciones preexistentes
siempre estarán ahí incluidos pero lo
que quisiera hacer es un sistema de
salud mucho mejor
siempre usted registremos a la gente a
la gente con condiciones pre-existentes
quisiera acabar con obama care y
quisiera tener un nuevo sistema de salud
los demócratas lo harán porque será
increíble ver mucha presión y
posiblemente tendremos la cámara para
ese punto y creo que vamos a retomar la
cámara esto de lo verán creo que vamos a
retomar la pero también vamos a
encontrar un mejor plan de salud siempre
protegiendo a la gente con condiciones
preexistentes y hay una cosa muy
importante hay 180 millones de personas
allá afuera que tienen un muy buen
seguro privado muchos más de los que
estamos hablando con obama que es yo
bailé va a terminar todas esas políticas
estas son personas que aman sus sistemas
de salud personas que han tenido éxito
personal de ingreso medio exitosos
180 millones de planes
180 millones de personas familias bajo
lo que él quiere hacer que básicamente
será socializar la medicina porque no
abre una opción ellos quieren acabar con
180 millones de plantas
hemos hecho un gran trabajo por el salud
y vamos a hacerlo incluso mejor
de acuerdo vicepresidente esta pregunta
es para usted su cuidado su ley de
cuidado dice que debemos basarnos en la
ley de obama care que haría usted en el
caso de que la corte suprema lo revierta
lo que voy a hacer es
dejar que siga el obamacare con una
opción pública una opción pública que
diga que si usted de hecho
está calificado para la ley de cuidado
de salud asequible
entonces lo puede hacer y está
inmediatamente
en esto y esto es lo que va a pasar en
segundo lugar vamos a asegurarnos de
reducir los precios de los medicamentos
al asegurarnos que la competencia que no
existe ahora
se le permitirá al programa la ley de
cuidado de salud negociar los precios en
tercer lugar lo que quiero decir que
quiero eliminar el seguro privado
es porque tengo 20 candidatos a la
nominación es porque yo apoyo el seguro
privado
ninguna de una sola ninguna persona va a
perder su seguro como no lo hicieron a
menos de que lo eligieran y eligieran
irse con alguien más y vamos a
asegurarnos de que si estamos en una
situación en la que podamos proteger no
hay ninguna parte esa manera en la que
él protege a las condiciones
preexistentes él ha estado hablando de
esto durante mucho tiempo y nunca ha
tenido un plan
y creo que va a tener un plan cuando
pasen en los sigan pasando los años dice
que se está poniendo ansiosa pero el
hecho es que
él ya le ha costado a los
estadounidenses muchas vidas por su mal
manejo del cob y 19 10 millones de
personas han perdido su seguro privado y
quiere quitárselo a 22 millones de
personas más que están bajo el obamacare
y va a perjudicar a 20 millones de
personas con condiciones preexistentes y
que van a ser ellos tengo un seguimiento
para ustedes vicepresidente que se
relaciona con algo que dijo el
presidente y que le dice a las personas
que tienen preocupaciones sobre su
cuidado de salud
lleva el país
más cerca a un sistema controlado por el
gobierno
la idea de que hay una opción pública
sobre la cual la gente puede elegir
instalación plan socialista la
diferencia es que el cuidado de la salud
no es un privilegio es un derecho y
todas las personas deberían tener acceso
a la salud y estoy muy orgulloso de mi
programa
está
respaldado por muchos sindicatos la
mayoría de los sindicatos que tenían
preocupaciones sobre el campo médico
también
esto le va a dar a las personas una
oportunidad de tener cuidado para sus
niños cuántos de ustedes están
preocupados y preguntándose sobre qué
van a hacer si se enferman porque
perdieron su seguro médico tenemos que
darle seguridad médica a las personas de
manera asequible presidente les estuvo
ahí por 47 años él no lo hizo ahora
estuvo como vicepresidente por 8 años y
no es como que fuera hace 25 años fue
hace tres años y tres cuartos fue hace
un poquito poquitico menos de cuatro
años él no hizo nada él no lo hizo él
quiere socializar la medicina y no es
que él quiere hacerlo él fue
vicepresidente es decir
bueno ella es más liberal que bernie
sanders y lo quiere más bernie sanders
quiere que eso pase los demócratas
quieren usted va a tener una medicina
socialista así como un el fracking no
vamos a obtener fracking vamos a dejar
de hacer fracking vamos a dejarlo y
luego cuando perciban ya recibe la
nominación que tuvo suerte va a
pensilvania y dice si vamos a hacer
fracking y nunca se hizo esa pregunta
por cierto hasta ahora yo respeto muy
bien la manera que está manejando usted
esto pero a veces alguien
pasó un año
[Música]
y no quiero responder mi respuesta es
que las personas merecen tener una ley
de cuidado de salud y acceso a la salud
oa precio asequible
y
si lo que tenemos que hacer es que nos
va a costar algo de dinero nos va a
costar más de 750 mil millones de
dólares hacerlo y necesitamos combinarlo
con planes más baratos y bajar los
planes premium
y tener otro tipo de cuentas y esto hará
que las medicinas bajen él sigue
hablando de esto pero no ha hecho nada
por nadie
socialista y de la salud bueno cuando él
habla de una opción pública él está
hablando de destruir el medicare yo
estoy completamente destruir su
seguridad social y este país se va a
derrumbar vértiz antes lo intentó lo
intentó en su estado lo intentó su
gobernador un hombre muy liberal quieren
hacerlo vamos a seguir y fue imposición
a respuesta del presidente él está muy
confundido piensa que está compitiendo
con alguien más está convirtiendo con
joe biden yo vencí a todas las otras
personas porque estuve en desacuerdo con
ellos está contra joe biden y la idea de
que estamos en una
en la que vamos a destruir la seguridad
médica esta es la persona que ha dicho
que si continúa con su plan
de poner impuestos a la seguridad social
esto para que entre en bancarrota
sin ninguna manera de retroceder esta es
la persona que ha tratado de cortar el
cuidado médico y la idea de que donald
trump me esté regalando a mí sobre
seguridad social
él
intentó acabar el seguro social ese años
hace muchos años por favor retrocedan
vean los registros el intento en
ese
tiempo de hablar de hacer un boom
rápidamente la idea de que los mercados
están
floreciendo es algo que ha pasado desde
antes hay personas que no viven de estos
tan solo en los últimos tres años
durante esta crisis los multimillonarios
en este país
ganaron 700 mil millones de dólares más
porque esa es su única medida lo que le
pasa a la gente común y corriente que
les pasa de ellos vamos a hablar sobre
lo que está pasando en
el techo él no viene de scranton tampoco
el vídeo y un periodo de tiempo muy
corto
se fue y la gente defensa era de
más de 20 millones de personas han
perdido su empleo y están cayendo en la
pobreza y cada vez más familias están
entrando en la hambruna
hay personas blancas y personas de color
están luchando por un plan de alivio
porque no les ha dado señor presidente
la ayuda que necesita nancy pelosi no
quiere aprobarlo yo quiero pero usted es
el presidente yo quiero hacerlo pero
todavía tengo que hacer que ya esté ahí
eso es las razones por las cuales creo
que vamos a tomar la cámara nancy pelosi
no quiere aprobar nada porque ella le
encantaría tener algunas victorias
en una fecha 3 de noviembre nancy pelosi
no quiere aprobarlo nosotros estamos
listos y estamos capaces para hacerlo no
olviden que ya hemos aprobado tres
planes y esto así esto ha pasado y
videos los demócratas esta vez ella no
lo quiere es acerca de elección es
porque ya cree que lo ayuda
políticamente y yo creo que solo va a
herir políticamente señor vicepresidente
el líder republicano en el senado
estadounidense dijo que no lo podía
aprobar él no iba a aprobar él no tiene
todos los votos republicanos porque él
no está hablando con tus amigos
republicanos
déjeme hacerle la pregunta usted es el
líder del partido demócrata porque usted
tampoco ha dicho nada los he empujado a
llegar a un acuerdo lo he hecho ellos
pasaron este proyecto de ley al
principio del verano esto no es nuevo ha
estado ahí
estas leyes y estos proyectos estarán
ahí esperando mire lo que están pasando
y cuando yo estuve a cargo de esto yo
pude conseguir 45 mil millones de
dólares para las comunidades para que
tuvieran un presupuesto
y tuvieron que despedir despedir a los
primeros respondientes a los bomberos
para que pudieran mantener a las
ciudades siguiendo adelante y él no
podía nada él no ha hecho nada por hecho
y mitch mcconnell dijo dice deje que
vayan a la bancarrota por favor cuál es
el problema con el acta fue pasada pero
eso fue una
fue un acta que estaba manejada por
demócratas que detenido tiene problemas
de crimen fue una manera de apropiarse
de millones de dólares y demandar las
acciones la mejor manera de recibir
mucho dinero del bolsillo de nuestra
gente
ahora la gente que llega nuestro país de
manera ilegal nosotros nos hemos
encargado de todo eso lo que esto hace a
mí me encantaría ayudarlos pero lo que
eso resulta haciendo es que en todo el
mundo la gente empezó a llegar a nuestro
país y nosotros no podemos hacerlo esa
fue una forma de cuidar desde sí es una
manera de evitar gastar en cosas que no
tienen nada que ver con covelia pero fue
realmente un gran pago
está muy mal no voy a recibir una
regañada
no veo estados rojos y estados azules lo
que yo veo es estados unidos de américa
si todos los estados ahí se encuentran
sin problemas y van a despedir gente ya
sean rojos
o azules van a empezar a despedir a
bomberos a profesores porque tienen que
entrar en un equilibrio en su
presupuesto y dejan que el gobierno para
el dictamine esto en estados unidos de
américa no quiero hablar sobre el
salario mínimo señor vicepresidente
estamos hablando mucho de los pequeños
negocios que están luchando en estos
días cree que este es el momento
correcto para pedirles que levanten el
salario mínimo sí creo que tenemos que
ayudarlos a ellos también debemos
ayudarles a estos negocios pequeños
hay unos que uno de cada seis está
cerrando y no van a poder volver
el dinero debería ir para ayudarlos para
organizarse a ver cómo pueden lidiar con
sus negocios para abrir con seguridad
como las escuelas pueden hacer clases
más pequeñas y contratar más maestros
ellos necesitan la ayuda los negocios
también y las escuelas también necesitan
la ayuda pero estos sujetos no los
quieren ayudar no les dan el dinero
creo dijo que tenemos que ayudar a los
negocios pequeños ayudando al subir
examen y wason ayuda pero creo que debe
ser un opción estatal alabama es
diferente nueva york nueva york es
diferente a vermouth cada estado es
diferente debería de ser una opción
estatal debemos poder ayudar esto es muy
importante de más para los negocios
pequeños como está ayudando a los
negocios pequeños cuando está forzando a
que la gente suba los salarios lo que es
comprobado es que cuando esto pasa los
negocios pequeños despiden a muchos de
sus empleados
es considerado elevar el salario mínimo
recientemente a 15 dólares
realmente lo que sí consideraría hasta
cierto punto lo que realmente quisiera
en la segunda ministración sí pero no un
nivel
en que ponga todos negocios afuera del
negocio es una opción distinta estado en
diferentes lugares sé que son diferentes
algunos sitios 15 dólares no está tan
grave en otros lugares en otros estados
15 dólares preferida manera rápida
respuesta vicepresidente dos trabajos un
trabajo
la gente está ganando seis o siete
dólares por hora cuando aplaudimos a
todos estos primeros respondientes que
está pasando ellos merecen un salario
mínimo de 15 dólares
y si no lo hacen los pobres los pones
por debajo del nivel de pobreza
esto sí no hace que tengan que salir de
los negocios y esto no es cierto
vamos a hablar sobre migración
señor vicepresidente presidente su
administración ha separado padres y
niños y desde entonces usted ha dado
reversa a su política
pero hay más de
como van a ser reunidas de estas
familias hijos son traídos acá por
coyotes y por gente muy mala sus
cárteles y los traen a car y los usan
para ingresarlos al país bueno ahora
tenemos unas fronteras mucho más fuertes
que nunca más de 400 millas de un muro
nuevo ustedes ven las cifras veamos que
entre la gente pero tienen que llegar
legalmente pero como va a decir ellos
construyeron jaulas decían que yo los
había construido pero luego tenía una
foto de él cierto periódico tiene una
foto de esas horribles jaulas y decía
miren estas jaulas del presidente atrás
las construyó y luego se determinó que
fueron construirse en 2014 y eso fue el
mando en ello estamos intentándolo pero
muchos de estos chicos salen sin sus
padres vienen a través de carteles a
través de coyotes a través de pandillas
estos niños llegaron con padres ellos
fueron separados en las fronteras
ellos serán muy fuertes y adivinen que
no son coyotes los que los trajeron
fueron padres que estaban con ellos y
ellos fueron separados de sus padres y
esto
viola todas las nociones sobre lo que
somos como nación y
lo hicieron y nosotros cambiamos la
política ellos hicieron y nosotros
cambiar a esto ellos
quien construyó las jaulas me gusta yo
de lo que estamos hablando que pasó los
padres fueron arrebatados de sus de los
brazos y ahora no pueden encontrar a
muchos de estos padres y estos niños
están solos no tienen a donde ir no
tienen a donde ir esto es criminal es
criminal
los reporteros y todos ellos están muy
bien cuidados están en instalaciones
limpios para algunas de las recibía
rondas con sus familias hay que hacer
una sola pregunta quién construyó las
jaulas quisiera que le preguntara él
déjeme preguntar sobre sus políticas de
migración en la administración obama que
no cumplió con su promesa de hacer una
reforma migratoria y también registró
récords de deportaciones en la frontera
antes de cambiar
porque deberían confiar los electores en
este derecho porque hicimos un
error que tomo demasiado tiempo en
corregirlo yo voy a ser presidente de
estados unidos no vicepresidente y el
hecho es que yo he dejado muy claro si
en 100 días voy a enviar al congreso
un camino a la ciudadanía para 11
millones de indocumentados y todos
aquellos llamados primer sus soñadores
los
beneficiarios del programa de acción
diferida van a quedar en este país con
un camino de la ciudadanía la idea de
este señor que quiere mandarlos a su
país ir a un país que nunca han visto
antes pueden imaginar esto que su usted
a los 5 años ustedes cruzar el río
grandes y le dijeran no mami voy a
quedarme aquí no voy a ir contigo
muchos de nuestros primeros
respondientes que estuvieron cuidando a
las personas durante esta crisis son
inmigrantes y les debemos esto
presidente son sus raíces mucho años
para hacer lo que dijo que va a hacer y
yo he cambiado sin tener algo específico
nos acabamos el atrapar y liberar nos
alejamos de una cantidad de cosas
ridículas que ellos establecieron pero
él tuvo ocho años como vicepresidente y
él no hizo nada a excepción de construir
jaulas para mantener a niños ahí
vicepresidente su respuesta
la ley d
capturar y liberar
esto es lo que él está hablando él se
les estaba dando en realidad una fecha
para ir
y llegaban en realidad la audiencia este
es el primer presidente de la historia
de eeuu que dice que usted debe pedir
asilo en otro país eso nunca había
pasado en eeuu
usted llega a eeuu y hace su caso y
presenta su caso y busca el asilo
pasando en esta premisa porque me lo
merezco bajo la ley estadounidense no lo
hacen al otro lado del río presidente
trump su respuesta es muy importante
simplemente se muestra que él no tiene
ninguna idea de migración o de ley
atrapar y liberar eso fue un desastre un
asesino llegaba un violador entraba una
persona muy mala entraba nosotros
tomábamos su nombre y teníamos que
liberarlo en nuestro país y luego se le
permitía volver menos de uno por ciento
de la gente vuelve tenemos que
encontrarlos tenemos que
y les vuelva en 23 años le vamos a dar
un caso de corte fue comprar y mason
cuando le dicen que devuelvan ellos se
devuelven
solamente los realmente bueno odio decir
esto pero aquellos que tienen el
coeficiente más bajo podría más
adelante y tenemos la oportunidad el
vicepresidente joe tu no conoces la ley
lo que él está diciendo no es cierto
ellos no vuelven ellos no vuelven pero
no tenemos que preocuparnos porque yo lo
acabo vamos a hacer una delante de alas
mientras sección hay muchos niños que no
saben dónde van a estar y dónde están
sus padres vamos a hablar sobre nuestra
siguiente sección que es la raza en eeuu
y quiero hablar sobre la manera en la
que los las personas de color están
esperando están experimentando la raza
en este país
esto pasa sin importar la raza en
los ingresos los padres no tienen
ninguna oportunidad más si no
prepararlas porque pueden ser objetivo
incluso de la policía por el único
motivo del color de su piel
pérez vicepresidente quiero que le hable
directamente a esas familias a ustedes
entiende porque estos padres tienen
miedo de lo que les va a pasar a sus
hijos si sus mi hija es una trabajadora
social
y ella ha escrito mucho sobre esto
para la universidad de pensilvania y
mucho más y una de las razones por las
que yo terminé trabajando con las
mujeres de delaware era aprender sobre
lo que estaba pasando nunca he dicho
esto a mi hija
si alguien se estaciona tiene que
asegurarse poner las dos manos sobre el
techo pero para que nadie los vaya a
detener pero un padre afroamericano
tiene que enseñarle esto a sus hijos no
tengas una capucha cuando camines por la
calle asegúrate de que si te detienen
digas si no señor y pongas las manos
sobre el vehículo porque puede
afectarte esto en una detención
el hecho de este asunto es que hay
racismo institucional en eeuu y siempre
hemos dicho nunca hemos hecho nada sobre
esto todos los hombres y mujeres
adivinen que
nunca hemos vivido sobre todo lo que
decimos y cada vez se mueve un poco más
la aguja hacia la inclusión y este es el
primer presidente en eeuu que ha dicho
que este es el final no lo vamos a hacer
más tenemos que darles oportunidades
económicas mejor educación mejor cuidado
de salud mejor acceso a las escuelas
mejor acceso a las oportunidades para
prestar que se les preste dinero para
empezar negocios todo esto es un plan
claro mío para decir cómo vamos a hacer
las cosas para darles a las personas una
oportunidad para que tengan también
riqueza para y así como hacer libres de
la violencia presidente es la misma
pregunta para usted quisiera que hablara
directamente a las familias sobre si
entendían por qué las familias a la
orgánica no temen por sus de nuevo
él es todo el gobierno por 47 años y
nunca hizo nada excepción en 1994 cuando
es tan grave daño a la comunidad afro y
en los llamamos super depredadores y él
dijo eso y lo dijo super depredadores
y no hemos podido acabar con eso 1994 el
acta de crimen super emprendedores nadie
ha hecho más para la comunidad negra que
donald trump si ustedes observan con la
excepción de abraham lincoln
posiblemente pero bueno la excepción de
abraham lincoln nadie ha hecho lo que yo
he hecho la reforma a la justicia
criminal
obama y joe no lo hicieron yo ni
siquiera creo que lo intentarán porque
no tenían opciones pudieron haber
querido hacerlo pero si si hubieran
visto los brazos que tuve que torcer
para lograrlo no fue bonito todo el
mundo lo sabe incluyendo algunos muy
liberales que lloraron en mi oficina
lloraron la oficina oval dos semanas
después estaban diciendo yo tenemos que
vencerlo en la justicia criminal la
reforma la reforma a la prisión también
trabajamos con tiempos con un gran
senador de cardinal sur llegó con esta
gran idea para las zonas de oportunidad
es uno de los programas más exitosos la
gente no habla de esos una gran
inversión que se está haciendo
los mayores beneficios son las
comunidades negras e hispánicas y luego
las comunidades las universidades
históricamente negros después de tres
años de visitar la oficina me encanta
llegar a la oficina y dicen me preguntan
qué están haciendo después de tres años
porque sigue envolviendo les pregunto es
por qué no tenemos patrocinio usted no
tiene que venir cada año nosotros
tenemos que volver dice porque
presidente obama nunca les hubiera dado
una patrocinio largo plazo y yo lo hice
diez años
pasó simple de compras y les ha dado más
dinero de lo que han pedido porque
siempre pensé que necesitaban más y creo
que la única parte triste eso es nunca
poder verlos de nuevo porque nos hicimos
buenos amigos yo les guste ellos me
gustan bueno bueno
apoya las comunidades de gracias inicias
historiales pero cuáles son respuesta mi
respuesta es que nunca ambas dije lo que
me acusa de decir el hecho es que en el
después de que esto pasará durante mucho
tiempo era que el problema era que no
había personas suficientes en la cárcel
y vayan a mi página y vean la cita que
él dijo
hablo de pandillas
ese es el hombre que decía en el central
park que los afroamericanos
y si alguna persona tuviera algún crimen
fuera recibiera la pena capital- y
hablando
de lo que él hizo en realidad 20
personas con perdonó a 20 personas
y la ley sobre la que le está hablando
es que una ley iniciado por barack obama
y en segundo lugar estamos en una
situación
en que el sistema federal de prisiones
fue reducido durante nuestra
administración y una de las cosas que
deberíamos hacer es que no debería haber
un mínimo obligatorio y por esto estoy
ofreciendo 20 millones de dólares para
eliminar los mínimos obligatorios nada
debería ir a la cárcel porque tienen un
problema con las drogas deberían ir a
rehabilitación no a la cárcel y esto
debemos cambiarlo de manera fundamental
y esto pero yo ya lo hizo hace cuatro
años porque no lo hiciste hace cuatro
años incluso menos porque no lo hiciste
fuiste vice presionante sigues hablando
de todas estas cosas que vas a hacer
pero estuviste ahí hace un tiempo y no
hicieron nada pero yo aspire a por ti yo
aspire la presidencia por barack obama
porque hicieron un trabajo terrible si
hubiera querido que hicieran que trabajo
no hubiera expirado y nunca lo hubiera
hecho yo aspire por ti durante mayo eres
un político y yo aspiro a esto por de
presidente baila en su respuesta a esto
y luego tengo algunas preguntas para
ambos les diré qué
espero que me vea porque lo que estaban
viendo acá y ustedes saben quién soy yo
ustedes saben quién es él ustedes
conocen su personalidad conocen la mía
conocen la reputación mía que es que
digo la verdad estoy ansioso por ver que
esto tenga lugar tengo la personalidad
nuestra personalidad está en la boleta
electoral por favor responda eso sí esto
es cierto sobre rusia sobre ucrania
china todos esos otros países irak si
esto es cierto entonces él es un
político corrupto pues no me hablen de
que como eres un bebé inocente yo te
están diciendo político corrupto nada de
admira
estamos hablando sobre el asunto de la
raza presidente estamos hablando sobre
la raza y quiero seguir sobre este
asunto pérez pero tengo que responder
por favor porque hay 50
ex agentes de seguridad que dicen que
sobre esto que me está acusando es un
plan de rusia han dicho que
hay cuatro personas que trabajaban en la
cia y que están diciendo que lo que él
dice es un montón de basura nadie lo
cree él cree que sus amigos están hablas
del laptop que habla de un engaño de un
caballero
conmigo vamos a continuar en el asunto
de las cuevas y regreso como describe
está descrito el movimiento blacklight
marc como un símbolo del odio
usted ha compartido
vídeos sobre el poder blanco y usted
cree que le dice a los estadounidenses
que dicen que este lenguaje de un
presidente contribuye a un clima de odio
en el valle porque la primera vez que yo
hablé de black que yo escuché de black
vice madre estaban cantando en cerdos en
sábanas cerdos hablan de la policía
que fría en los cómodos y fuera en
tocino y pensé que era horrible estaba
marchando en las calles y esa fue la
primera vez
que yo tuve un vistazo de blacklight
matters pensé que era algo terrible
bueno respecto a mi relación con todas
las personas creo que tengo grandes
excelentes relaciones con todo el mundo
soy la persona menos racista en esta
habitación que le decimos que hay que
decir tuve la reforma de la justicia
criminal la forma carcelaria las zonas
de seguridad me encargue de las
universidades negras no sé qué decir
dios puedes decir cualquier cosa ellos
pueden decirlo
me entristece porque yo soy la persona
menos racista ni siquiera puedo ver a la
audiencia porque está tan oscuro porque
no sé quién está en la audiencia soy la
persona menos racista en esta habitación
de acuerdo vicepresidente biden déjeme
preguntarle muy rápidamente
abraham lincoln es uno de los
presidentes más racistas de
cada uno de ellos ha preguntado con su
campaña ha empezado a diciendo que se va
a deshacer de los mexicanos el blog que
hoy prohibió el ingreso de los
musulmanes simplemente porque son
musulmanes de la hecho mucho peor todo
en la frontera y dice esto sobre los
pobres chicos
dijo que
tienen que estar listos es por supuesto
que este hombre simplemente es tan falso
y racista
él hizo una referencia abraham lincoln
de dónde salió eso
no no no yo os dije que no desde abraham
lincoln nadie ha hecho nada lo que yo he
hecho por la comunidad de grant y yo
digo que soy abraham lincoln yo dije
nadie desde abraham lincoln ha hecho lo
que yo he hecho por la comunidad de gra
ahora tú no has hecho nada distinto al
acta del crimen
a decenas de miles de hombres negros
sobre todo
ellos
no sé lo que es
le doy la oportunidad de responder las
leyes criminales que usted apoyó en los
80 y los 90 contribuyeron a la
encarcelación de muchos jóvenes
negros son hijos son familias que aún
ahora están sufriendo las consecuencias
así que hable a estas familias porque
deberían votar por los temas una de las
cosas es que en los ochentas aprobamos
el 100 por ciento todos los senadores
votaron en un proyecto de ley sobre
drogas y cómo lidiar con las drogas fue
un error he tratado de estar
cambiando esto sobre todo en lo que
respecta a la cocaína
no deberíamos enviar a nadie a la cárcel
por una ofensa de drogas deberían ir a
tratamiento
esto es lo que deberíamos gastar nuestro
dinero
ellos deberían no ir a la cárcel por un
problema de drogas o de alcohol sino que
deberían ir a tratamiento tratamiento
esto es lo que estamos tratando de hacer
y esto es lo que yo voy a hacer
porque los estadounidenses ahora están
viendo que de hecho fue un error aprobar
esas leyes pero no están en la ley
porque no
es solamente charla nada de acción con
estos políticos porque él no lo logró
eso es lo que yo voy a hacer cuando me
vuelvo presidente fuiste vicepresidente
junto con obama y él fue presidente fue
tu líder por 8 años porque no lo hiciste
ocho años para hacerlo ahora estás
diciendo que lo vas a hacer porque
solamente hablas si no haces hicimos
mucho de las cosas no hiciste nada
liberamos a 31 mil prisioneros 38 mil
fueron liberados de presiones federales
hay más de 1000 personas que recibieron
la clemencia y fuimos nosotros los que
pusimos la legislación que se podía ver
en los departamentos de policía para ver
cómo se estaban comportando y podría
continuar pero nosotros empezamos el
proceso empezamos el proceso perdimos
una elección y por eso estoy ahora para
volver y cambiar todo esto y solamente
hay que hacer una pregunta por qué y no
hiciste eso en los 8 años hace un poco
tiempo porque no lo hiciste dijiste voy
a hacer esto voy a hacer aquello
puso arte a decenas de miles de sobre
todo jóvenes negros en la prisión ahora
dices que voy a hacer eso porque no lo
hiciste tuviste ocho años con obama
porque que yo porque solamente hable si
no haces porque el 20 presidente vamos a
seguir adelante con la siguiente sección
porque hay un congreso republicano
esa es la respuesta tienes que hablar
tienes que convencerlos a veces hay que
conversar los vamos a seguir con nuestra
como yo lo hice con la reforma de la
justicia criminal yo tuve que convencer
a los demócratas nosotros sencillamente
se nos está acabando el tiempo y vamos a
hablar de cambio climático ustedes
tienen visiones muy diferentes sobre el
cambio climático el presidente siempre
ha dicho que las regulaciones han herido
los empleos han dañado los empleos y
usted vicepresidente lo ve como una
oportunidad para crear nuevos empleos
para cada uno de ustedes cómo van a
llevar a cabo
las políticas contra el cambio climático
y al mismo tiempo apoyar el buen
movimiento tenemos el programa del
trillón de árboles tenemos muchos
programas distintos yo amo el medio dice
pero lo que quiero es el agua más limpia
el aire más limpio
tenemos los números más bajos en
emisiones de carbono que es un gran
estándar que se que obama y menciona
todo el tiempo y no yo yo he escuchado
yo hablar de eso porque bueno no creo
que él sepa qué significa pero escuchado
vamos a utilizarlo y tenemos
las mejores cifras de emisión de carbono
que hemos tenido en 35 años bajo esta
administración estamos trabajando muy
bien con la industria pero eso es lo que
no podemos hacer miren a china los
mugrosos sucio que es mira rusia
mira y es muy groso el aire es terrible
asqueroso el acuerdo de parís nos saque
de ahí porque íbamos a tener que gastar
billones de dólares y se nos trató muy
injustamente cuando él nos incluye y nos
hizo un servicio terrible iban a tomar
los negocios y yo no voy a sacrificar a
decenas de millones de trabajos miles y
miles de compañías por el acuerdo de
parís fue tan injusto china ni siquiera
empresa 2020 2030 en rusia vuelven
estándar bajo y nosotros empezamos ahí
si hubiéramos arrancado hubiera
destruido todos nuestros negocios
entonces están listos hemos hecho un
gran trabajo muy ambientalmente tenemos
el aire más limpio el agua más limpia y
los mejores estándares de emisión de
carbono que hemos visto en muchos muchos
años
y no hemos destruido nuestras industrias
vicepresidente vaya en dos minutos sin
interrupciones el cambio climático y el
calentamiento global es la siguiente
amenaza contra la humanidad tenemos una
obligación moral para lidiar con esto y
nos dicen todos los científicos en el
mundo que no tenemos mucho tiempo vamos
a pasar el punto de no retorno en los
próximos 8 a 10 años este hombre ha
eliminado todas las regulaciones
regulaciones para limpiar
para limitar las emisiones y nos va a
poner en una posición en la que vamos a
estar en grandes graves problemas yo
pude
lograr el apoyo de las organizaciones
del cambio climático así como de las
personas que se preocupan por los
empleos
y mi plan crea nuevos empleos que pagan
bien vamos a invertir
en 500 mil 50 mil
estaciones en nuestras
avenidas para que podamos alimentar el
mercado de carros eléctricos y vamos a
estar en una posición en la que vamos a
tomar
4 millones de
hogares y de edificios y vamos a
transformar su energía para
ahorrar miles de millones de barriles de
petróleo y esto va a incrementar los
empleos y toda la idea de que esto va a
ser va a crear millones de empleos y
vamos a limpiar nuestro medio ambiente y
esto es lo que está pasando y ahora en
este momento wall street ha indicado que
mi plan
va de hecho a crear
más de 18 millones de empleos 7 millones
más que el de elx y va a crear 3 mil
millones más de crecimiento económico
que su propuesta no sólo en el clima
sino en la economía
bueno se dijo hoy
650 veces eran asumidos serán tomado de
la familia para su plan ese plan es un
desastre económico y si se mira lo que
él quiere hacer si miren su plan su plan
media mental sabe que uno de sancho
alzando casi tres y esos tres amigas sí
que no saben nada sobre el clima es
decir tienen una serie de buenos
discursos pero no saben nada del clima y
todos están saltando
junto con alexandra ocasión cortes cuero
miren un plan real cuesta 100 millones
de dólares si tuviéramos el mejor año en
la historia de nuestro país por 100 años
ni siquiera nos podemos acercar unas
cifras y cuando él habla edificios de
ellos quieren tu pareja y sus prefieren
hacer ventanas más grandes y
convertirlas en más pequeñas que
respecta a ellos si no hubiera ventanas
sería maravilloso de esta es el plan más
loco que cualquiera haya visto y eso no
fue hecho por gente inteligente esto no
fue hecho por nadie francamente ni
siquiera sé cómo puede serlo
prácticamente ellos quieren gastar 100
billones de dólares el número real está
diciendo que eran 6 100 millones de
dólares ellos quieren tomar edificios y
construir edificios nuevos con ventanas
pequeñísimas y muchas otras muchas otras
cosas
donde tenemos muy va a destruir nuestro
pueblo escuchar al vicepresidente
no sé de dónde viene esto de dónde saca
estos números
100.000 millones de dólares deme un
respiro de este plan fue respaldado por
todos los alcaldes y por todos los ricos
sindicatos porque saben que el futuro
está en que nosotros podamos respirar y
saben que hay buenos empleos y el
crecimiento más grande de la industria
con crecimiento más grande
es la energía solar y el la energía del
viento
es la economía con empleos que más crece
y paga muy bien a
45 a 60 dólares a la hora podemos crecer
y ser más limpios si seguimos la ruta
que propongo
somos independientes energéticamente por
primera vez no necesitamos a estos
países con los que tenemos que luchar
guerras porque necesitábamos energía
somos independientes
temas del viento que usted es
extremadamente
bueno costoso matando de las aves es
completamente intermitente tiene muchos
problemas y resulta que bueno los
molinos son hechos en alemania y en
china y si usted cree en las emisiones
de carbono de estos vapores que salen de
ahí para hacer estos increíbles molinos
consumen y bueno contaminan más que el
gas natural que cualquier otra cosa ya
solamente otra energía solar pero
todavía en esta lista no es
suficientemente poderosa para realmente
manejar nuestras grandes y hermosas
fábricas que necesitamos para competir
con el mundo es falso es un sueño dorado
pero sabes que pasarás nosotros vamos a
construir la mejor economía del mundo
pero si tú quieres economía
aléjate de esa industria petrolera y
responde nunca he dicho que me opongo al
frac club dijiste y está grabado muestra
la grabación
el hecho es que si le está mintiendo
si lo permitiré porque la respuesta que
necesitamos es que necesitamos otras
industrias que hagan la transición
hasta que lleguemos a las emisiones cero
a 2025 lo que me voy a asegurar es que
capturemos estas emisiones de el
fracking que podemos hacer esto y
podemos hacerlo al invertir dinero es
una transición hacia esto tengo una
pregunta más de un momento él dijo que
estaba en contra del fracking él lo dijo
yo les voy a mostrar en su mañana yo
estoy en contra del fracking hasta que
recibí la nominación y fue a pensilvania
y dijo saben qué pensilvania voy a estar
en contra eso es el país el partido que
están claros
tierras federal viste lo que dije deben
de hacer esta pregunta última pregunta
en la sección presidente de trump la
gente de color
tiene más probabilidad de vivir en
tierras con químicos y con residuos de
crudo su administración ha llevado hacia
atrás las regulaciones sobre este tipo
de instalaciones que le va a dar a las
familias que estamos discutiendo
tienen empleo están haciendo dinero más
dinero que el que nunca han hecho si
observamos el tipo de números que hemos
producido para los hispanos para la
comunidad negra para los asiáticos 9
meses superior a la ganancia porcentual
en tres años que bajo ocho años de los
dos de ellos para ponerlo de una manera
correcta nueve veces más ahora
alguien que vive bueno yo nunca
escuchado de estas cifras las
estadísticas que están mencionando pero
están haciendo una gran cantidad de
dinero y económicamente lo salvamos y lo
salve de nuevo hace unos cuantos meses
cuando el petróleo estaba derrumbándose
por la pandemia vamos esto estamos
hablando de una mala relación pero
decimos que arabia saudita méxico y
rusia
recordarán para nosotros a berlín 12
petrolera y ahora
todos tienen un avance y vamos a seguir
una pregunta final para cada uno mi
respuesta es que estas personas se
llaman en la línea límites él no lo
entiende viven cerca a las plantas
químicas que contaminan y las refinerías
que contaminan y yo solía vivir cerca de
una de estas en delaware
y
allá hay más refinerías que ningún otro
lugar y mi madre me llevaba a la escuela
y veíamos como había humo por la ventana
y por eso hay que tantas personas que
tienen cáncer en mi estado y están
muriendo y no importa cuánto les están
pagando sino como los mantienes a salvo
que hacemos impone duras fricciones
sobre la contaminación
para que sobre estas personas que están
en la línea límite tengo una pregunta a
esa industria petrolera cerrar y deben
saber hay una transición si hay una
transición es una gran declaración
porque voy a detener porque la industria
del crudo contamina significa su amigo
gran declaración si me deja terminar la
declaración porque tiene que ser
reemplazada por energía renovable con el
tiempo y le he dicho
que le dejaré de dar subsidios federales
a las compañías
le vamos a dar en vez de impuestos
la mayor declaración de negocios la
mayoría acuerdo
final
la industria petrolera van a recordar
eso en texas van a recordar eso el
principal mío cajón vicepresidente de
bailén déjeme dar bien segundos
el cauca el toma todo y lo saca de
contexto tenemos que seguir hacia
emisiones 0 el primer lugar en hacer
esto para 2035 va a aumentar su
producción va a ser que chino lo haremos
una pregunta que chile lo haga no voy a
rehacer el acuerdo de parís y voy a
hacer que china con gol de buscarle me
prometió esto es sobre liderazgo
caballeros y la primera pregunta para
usted presidente de trump imagina que
este su día de juramentación que va a
decirle a los estadounidenses que no
votaron por usted cada uno tiene un
minuto tenemos que hacer que nuestro
país sea completamente exitoso como lo
era antes de la placa que llegó de china
ahora estamos reconstruyendo y lo
estamos logrando cifras récords 11.4
millones de trabajos en un corto periodo
de tiempo pero voy a decir lo vuelvan
antes de que llegara la plaga justo
antes es ahora haciendo llamadas de
personas que no eran personas que me
llevarían normalmente ellos querían
reunirse teníamos
las mejores cifras de desempleo afro en
el país de hispanos de mujeres de
asiáticos gente con diploma sin diplomas
graduados de ley mighty número 1 de su
clase todos tenían las mejores ciencias
y saben que el segundo el otro lado
quería reunirse y quería unificarse el
éxito nos va a reunir nosotros estamos
en camino al éxito pero yo he recortado
impuestos si él quiere aumentar los los
impuestos de todos él quiere poner
regulaciones nuevas sobre todos él va a
matar esto y si él entra habrá una
depresión como nunca han visto antes sus
force one keys van a irse a el infierno
y va a ser un día muy triste para el
vicepresidente baile en la misma
pregunta que le dirá
y estadounidenses que no votaron por
está el día de su inauguración les diré
que soy el presidente de eeuu y
represento a todos ustedes y votaron por
mí o en contra de mí y me voy a asegurar
de que estén representados les voy a dar
esperanza vamos a avanzar vamos a elegir
las ciencias sobre la ficción vamos a
elegir la certeza sobre el miedo y
tenemos una oportunidad enorme para
hacer que las cosas mejoren podemos
crecer esta economía y podemos lidiar
con el racismo sistémico y al mismo
tiempo podemos asegurarnos de que
nuestra economía esté siendo moldeada y
muy motivada por la energía limpia para
crear millones de empleos y eso es lo
que vamos a hacer estos son hechos y les
voy a decir cómo lo he hecho desde el
principio lo que está en la boleta
electoral es el carácter de este país la
decencia del honor el respeto tratar a
la gente con dignidad asegurarnos de que
todos tengamos una oportunidad
equitativa y me voy a asegurar de que lo
tengamos porque no lo tuvimos durante
los últimos cuatro años
quiero agradecerles a ambos por esta
hora y media de debate fantástico
presidente trump y vicepresidente joe
biden gracias a la universidad por ser
nuestro anfitrión esta noche y gracias a
todos ustedes por vernos esta noche la
elección es el 3 de noviembre no olviden
votar gracias a todos tengan una buena
noche
[Aplausos]